YEARS, CAN HE GET TO MINE?
MATTHEWS IN
FRONT
RINGS IT IN, THAT SHOT INTO THE
GLOVE!
AND TAVARES LOOSE, TAVARES SIDE
E
LEAFS THREE SHIFTS IN A
JOHANS MIDDLE OF THEN FRONT!
AND KERFOOT YOU'RE NOT SUPPOSEDO
SCORE BUT IT IS FUN ONCE INIE RR
THE ZONE. BACK
ONSIDE.
GOOD MOVEHE LEAFS COME, RIELLY
SHOOTS!
GOOD STOP BY SAMSONOV, ANOTHER
BLAST, SCORES!
[ Cheering ]
JUST 11 S SHE'LL DRIVE PLAY IN.
NYLANDER BACKDOORY SAMSONOV.
SAMSONOV MAKES A TERRIFIC STOP
BUT FT.
MIKLHEYEV SPINNING AROUND AS
VANECEK UNDER SIEGE SINCEEIS FOS
FOREVER.
ZONE.
VAN RIEMSDYK LOST IT, TWO-ON-ONE
FOR THE LEAFS,, PULL AWAY
THIS SECOND PERIOD, FINAL MINUTE
AT SCOTIABANK ARENA.
AND THIS PUCK RIGHTHT, IT
TURNED, JUST ALL THE WAY FOR
TORONTO AS THE
STRETCH, RAY.
THE CAPITALS AND THE WILD IN
PLAYOFF POSITION, WE E
THE NET HE GOES!
GARNET HATHAWAY, JENS
AND BACK FORCKSTROM IN A BATTLEH